et on va démarrer par celui qui a joué
des années dans sous le soleil
aujourd'hui il vient présenter son
nouveau film [ __ ] dans la ville et sur
la ville ce sort sur la ville merci
d'accueillir bernard montiel merci
[Applaudissements]
à l'émotion
à temps de m'y
attendais
je suis quand même le seul journaliste
qui parle mal aux stars
mais non vous êtes très beau merci
accompagnent mais ben merci passons
maintenant à celle qui vient pour un
film hors compétition au nom évocateur
il n'y a pas que des écureuils qui
bouffent des glands daniel moreau
[Musique]
arnaud calbry
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît on va
accueillir maintenant l'une des stars
montantes du cinéma international est
aussi celui qui avait joué donc beaucoup
de films il a récemment joué dans
l'excellent film vol au-dessus d'un nid
de caucus et gilles verdez
[Musique]
les autres bars en bars contre lui
marc toi tu me dégoûtes si vous partout
à part toi tu me dégoûtes on va
accueillir maintenant la benjamine de ce
festival s'est fait remarquer avec son
remake d'un film de patrick dewaere avec
patrick dewaere et gérard depardieu les
femmes porteuses kelly bédouine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez il faut rester cohérent slim reste
vous pouvez rester oui les autres lent
parce qu'il était dégueulasse mais vous
le bad boy du cinéma a aussi fait le
déplacement son livre livreur the top
qui raconte l'histoire d'un chauffeur
livreur qui fait débat de faire dans des
pmu est un carton ovation pour raymond à
bout
tu
es toujours au rayon perso
j'adore choplin bâti merci allez-y tous
les deux bravo magnifique regarder quel
beau couple magnifique n'en est
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
place à la maman du cinéma unique une
icône du petit écran elle concourt ce
soir avec son film le fabuleux destin de
beverly choukroun valérie benaïm
st
excusez moi
c'est moi à cette limousine j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans rabbi jacob
yacouba une personne dedans mais sans
éclat c'est l'incroyable pas qu'il ya
des gens qui arrivent et encore merci
ouais c'est un truc de fou marc vous
êtes très bien la passion photocall
merci masse au photocall il nous
présente son premier long métrage pigeon
break qui raconte l'histoire d'un mec
super blindé qui essaient de s'échapper
d'une boutique de luxe qui parce qu'on
veut lui vendre des trucs super moche
c'est bien sûr guillaume genton
c'est pas du lin j'aime bien c'est pas
de l'argent mais ni mes deux passions le
cinéma et le futsal c'est pas nul c'est
que c'est pas nul merci merci à vous
c'est pas nul franchement c'est pas nul
hein tu es tu sais que c'est pas nul du
doubs c'est une vraie proposition
j'adore c'est vraiment une vraie vraie
proposition jeu toujours serré c'est
bravo bravo toujours très fière de toi
je suis très très fier de temps les
chéris elle est avec nous ce soir elle a
joué dans tout pour le vaccin
bien entendu c'est géraldine maillet qui
t'avait coup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais j'aime bien cette scène on ne sait
pas sur votre salle marcel franchement
drôles j'adore aller au bal en irak
indoor qui oublie j'adore tes
magnifiques j'aurais dit oui et enfin on
termine en beauté par un grand nom du
cinéma français elle nous fait l'honneur
d'être avec nous ce soir pour la
projection de son film et y boobs
benjamin castaldi benjamines arrière
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais te faire tomber non non
m'arrête je vais te taper vêtements
merci ils venaient merci merci merci
merci aux équipes qui ont fait un
travail exceptionnel mais bien la côte
belge peut pas couvrir la barre avec toi
c'est d'accord sur la toile fond ne
tombait pas les chiroux d'inquiéter pa
cotation et le temps en attendant c'est
le 6 à 7 alors là vous voyez on va
envoyer les cool ce foyer des plateaux
voilà rien passé un bordel on adore on
est bien mais tu
peux être manié le q7 fait je boite
c'est par là on passe ma part c'est pas
la peine non là c'est un grenier
d'accord très bien merci nous sommes
dans les arcanes bien sûr de tpm paix du
sis à cet endroit cette émission à
succès bahman toile
attention de tomber les chéris attention
tombait pas on s'en fout vous inquiétez
pas en haletant vous inquiétez battu
gijon assez sûr betty
boop j'ai la jambe cassée mais merci ils
à avoir pu si l'agent k c'est ce qu'on
les ramène toi mais je veux pas couvrir
magne toi le cul sur talons plus magne
toi le cul malgré ça je vois mon cul je
faisais moins il ya castaldi là derrière
c'est insupportable merci d'être avec
nous autres cas bonsoir comment ça va
mon soir bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir merci merci d'être là
merci d'être là les séries
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mettez visite médicale british
enfin
[Applaudissements]
non